in 2020 it cost more than 447 000
to imprison just one inmate in a new
york city jail per year
447 000 and this is just your
run-of-the-mill jail in new york city
not a maximum security prison where you
get sent once you've already been
convicted of a crime
where you can imagine there being a lot
more operating expenses
no but a jail where you go to if you get
pulled over for drunk driving or you get
caught with some drugs on you and you're
awaiting trial
which to be fair does include the
infamous rikers island jail
the biggest jail complex in america that
is very brutal
if you could survive righteous island
you can survive anything that will
average out to 447
000 per year at that rate you can live
in the world's only 7 star hotel in
dubai
the burj al-arab or the mandarin
oriental overlooking central park in
manhattan
or the la reserve in perry if that's
more of your style
but in an nyc jail you're going to have
a much better time
this 447 thousand dollar price tag is up
from the 334 000
it was in 2019 while at the same time
jail population went down and violence
went up around the same amounts
so there were less inmates to manage yet
the cost went up by over a hundred
thousand dollars
that half a million dollars per inmate
has to go somewhere
the question is where this is the
profitable business of the prison
industrial complex
some of the footage you see in this
video is from storyblocks today's video
sponsor
storyblocks is the all-in-one platform
that lets you download unlimited stock
video audio music stock images
animations
basically all the assets that you could
need to make a video storyblocks has
them all in one place with a single
affordable subscription
and that's what i love about storyblocks
a lot of other platforms offer you just
music or just stock video with a
subscription
or worse yet some charge you per
download with storyblocks you get
everything with unlimited downloads all
in one very reasonable subscription
so you can create eye popping stuff like
this
[Applause]
[Music]
it's faster and easier than ever before
and the best part
if you're brand new to editing
storyblocks even offers an easy to use
video editor that lets you add content
directly from their library
intuitively edit then you can download
your new video and all the important
aspect ratios
so if you're an aspiring creator
marketer or editor that wants to make
videos faster than ever before
pause the video and go to
storyblocks.comtrend right now with the
link below to sign up for their
unlimited all access plan
there's no commitment and you can cancel
at any time that's storyblocks.comtran
with the link below
[Music]
around the world there are over 10
million people held in prison
with the leader of the prison industrial
complex being none other than the united
states
yes the land of the free home of the
brave has not only the highest number of
prisoners
but also has the most prisoners per
capita the u.s shares the stage right
above el salvador
turkmenistan and thailand in per capita
terms
[Music]
in terms of just the raw number of
prisoners the u.s has around 2.1 million
people incarcerated
followed by china at 1.7 million brazil
at 800 000 russia at 500
000 and india at around 470 000.
but these numbers can be deceiving see
on paper
china has only four hundred thousand
less prisoners than the us
a pretty small margin but china is also
pretty well known for releasing false
data to the world since their government
has total control over their numbers
china has also been routing up a muslim
minority that lives in their borders
called uyghurs
and throwing them into prison camps
labor camps but instead of labeling them
as
prison labor camps they refer to them as
vocational
educational and training centers
some estimates put the number of uyghurs
locked up in these training centers at 1
million
and i highly doubt this 1 million or
whatever the real number is of
vocational trainees are included in
their prisoner statistics
[Music]
and if that's the case china could
easily overtake the us for the most
humans imprisoned
definitely doesn't take away from the
us's giant prison population
but still important to keep in mind but
why what's the point of having all these
people held in captivity that you have
to feed manage and somewhat provide for
simple it's pretty profitable for almost
all the parties involved
and at least in the us's case this
business this pipeline if you want to
call it that
starts at the street level
most people know that in america you're
innocent until proven guilty
but not your property yes in america
police can take your property without
ever arresting you or charging you with
a crime
carrying too much cash police can accuse
you of selling drugs or laundering money
and
seize it seize it without ever taking
you to court
and police departments around the
country have discovered this is a really
good way
to raise money as long as they can claim
that they suspect your house your car
your jewelry your cash might be
connected to a crime
they can come and take it they know
better
under asset forfeiture the government
doesn't need anything but suspicion to
seize your property and keep it for
themselves
police then get to keep the toys they
like auction off the rest
and use the money for whatever they want
salaries equipment
trips whatever when the police sees
things they get to keep the money they
can use it for salaries they can use it
for trips and one
police department used the money to buy
a margarita machine but
i gather that most of the time they're
using it for
police equipment as one police chief put
it
it's kind of like pennies from heaven
you know it gets you a toy or something
that you need is the way
we typically look at it there's some
limitations on it you know it's
actually there's not really on the
forfeiture stuff and the great part
since this is a civil case not a
criminal case the court doesn't have to
provide the person you took from with a
lawyer if they can't afford
one so they have to fight it themselves
pay their own fees prove that their
property is innocent
after it's been taken away so most of
the time they just end up giving up
under asset forfeiture law enforcement
seize your property without
arresting you charging you or convicting
you of a crime the guy whose stuff is
taken he can
fight in court to get it back he has to
prove that it's legally there and that
can cost him
ten thousand or a hundred thousand legal
fees most people just give up and lose
their stuff
it's your property that gets charged and
you must prove
that it isn't guilty and with this
incentive of
asset forfeiture in place police
departments have gotten very clever with
it
you could seize a car full of drugs or
you can let the drug dealer sell the
drugs and seize a car full of money
so which sides of the highways do you
think police set stings up on
they set up stings on the side of the
highways where they know the drug
dealers are leaving town with cars full
of money
not the sides where the police where the
drug dealers are coming into town with
cars full of drugs
and it's gotten so profitable that by
2014 law enforcement took more stuff
from people
than actual burglars
[Music]
you know congress gave acid forfeiture
to the government
to prosecute the war on drugs and this
is
turned into a massive revenue stream and
after 40 years of war on drugs
we still have drugs and drug dealers you
know the only thing we've really
forfeited is their
rights to property and to liberty all
this happens without requiring an arrest
which brings us to the next step in the
pipeline the actual prisons and jails
if you want to be a prison entrepreneur
the business model of prisons is pretty
simple
when the war on drugs was at its peak
government prisons were getting too
crowded and couldn't keep up
so private companies pitched to the
government that if you contract the work
to us
we can build the prisons you need faster
make them safer at a lower cost
a very compelling argument so the
government said yes
even though the last part about lowering
costs didn't pan out so well
private prison companies could build
facilities faster
without voter approval they also claimed
they could provide a higher quality
at a lower price so today the job of the
prison entrepreneur is to secure
government contracts to build and run
prisons
and the prisons you run you charge a
daily fee per prisoner
but as always we don't call this rate
your per inmate fee
because that would come off a little too
inhumane to the public
so like all questionable things you it
with obscure
terminology like per diem or mandates
which is just a fancy name for what you
charge per prisoner per day
so if you want to make more money all
you have to do is either increase the
price each prisoner pays per day
lower your operating costs or increase
the number of customers in your
facilities
but in reality private prisons only make
up around eight percent of the industry
which is not a lot
so why do public prisons and jails like
the ones in new york city still cost so
much
simple it's the same reason why san
francisco spent 16 million dollars
to set up 262 tents for homeless people
not 262 homes but a literal tent
in a white square painted on the floor
which comes out to 61 000
per tenth per year which is 2.5 times
more than what it costs to rent a one
bedroom apartment in the same city
there's so many scandals by the way
there was one just reported in the
censure chronicle
about how the city of san francisco paid
16 million dollars
to pay for something like 260 tenths or
something like that
why because someone's got to provide the
city with tents at inflated prices
someone's got to paint the squares on
the floor at inflated prices
because why not the government's paying
they're not gonna blink an eye at an
extra few thousand dollars
it's not their money and it makes them
look good that they're caring for
homeless people
the same is true for public prisons sure
the government is the one running them
but they still have to buy uniforms food
from other contractors to keep the show
going
so we covered the police we covered the
prisons but there's one more part of
this prison economy that we haven't
covered yet
the cheap labor
let's say you're running a company that
needs some simple manual labor
maybe the sewing cleaning or
manufacturing jobs on one hand you could
hire a normal free citizen
but then you have to pay them at market
wages maybe offer
benefits 401ks deal with labor unions
it's just a pain on the other hand some
of these jobs can be outsourced to
cheaper countries
but now you have the added layer of
complexity of dealing with shipping and
all those logistics
it's also a pain enter prison labor
their domestic you pay them pennies on
the dollar and they can't complain
now i am not saying that if i needed
workers like these i would choose this
ladder option
but it's definitely compelling and this
is another huge incentive to keep this
train going
10 million people incarcerated around
the world as one heck of a workforce
most prisoners in the us work these
basic jobs same thing with the trainees
in china's labor camps
and this is what happens when all these
different parties come together
police prosecutors public prisons
private prisons government contractors
companies that hire prison labor
but to be fair some prisons are a lot
better than others and how much they
cost and how they treat their inmates
like this private prison cnbc cover that
charges only 51 dollars per person
per day and looks pretty decent at least
what they showed on camera and there are
a lot of prisoners that i would be happy
to continue paying a reasonable amount
to keep them behind bars
but 447 thousand dollars per inmate per
year in nyc
in what world does that make sense a lot
of people blame private prisons because
they're an easy targets
but again they only manage eight percent
of the inmates in america
if you ban private prisons the exact
same problems would just move back into
the public prisons
so what about taking a look at the legal
system that makes this mass
incarceration possible
or the 300 000 plus federal crimes that
are on the books
or the fact that 98 of those federal
crimes aren't even written by elected
officials
300 000 plus that's just federal it's
way
way too big part of that is because we
don't take any
old or outmoded laws off the book that's
not how it works in practice
at the federal level 98 percent of
criminal laws
are not passed by elected
representatives
when you give the government this kind
of power they're going to exercise it at
some point people commit crimes
all the time without knowing it because
it's impossible to know what sort of
behavior is criminal when they get
labeled as criminals that stays with
them through their whole life
so i will leave you with this there is
no way to rule innocent men
the only power any government has is the
power to crack down on criminals
well when there aren't enough criminals
one makes them
one declares so many things to be a
crime that it becomes impossible for men
to live without breaking laws
who wants a nation of law-abiding
citizens what's there not for anyone
but just past the kind of loss that can
nearly be observed nor enforced nor
objectively interpreted
and you create a nation of law breakers
and then
you cash in on guilt
[Music]
if you enjoyed this video don't forget
about storyblocks because they help make
videos like this possible
storyblocks is the go-to place for
unlimited stock video animation stock
music stock images everything you need
to create videos all in one
affordable simple subscription so make
your life easier and this channel's life
easier by going to storyblocks.com
jake tran with the link below to sign up
right now there's no commitment you can
cancel at any time at storyblocks.com
jake tran with the link below if you are
new here we make video essays just like
this one every single week for free so
you might also subscribe
we're almost at half a million
subscribers which i'm pretty pumped
about
so click that red button below and if
you want more behind the scenes stuff
than the life kind of stuff
lots of business memes you can follow me
on instagram jaketrend.io we have a ton
of fun over there
that is going to wrap it up for this
video thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
stay out of prison too
[Music]